♪
STEVE: MICHIGAN BARBER KARL
MANKE HAS BEEN FIGHTING THE
LOCKDOWNS IN HIS STATE.
HIS PATEL ISN’T OVER YET.
NOW HE HAS BEEN FINED $9,000
FOR, AMONG OTHER THINGS,
CARRYING A COMB IN HIS POCKET.
NOT MAKING IT UP.
KARL AND HIS ATTORNEY DAVID JOIN
US NOW.
GUYS, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, HOW ARE YOU?
STEVE: I’M DOING OKAY.
KARL, YOU ARE A BARBER.
AND YOU ARE BEING FINED $9,000
FOR, AMONG OTHER THINGS, FOR
HAVING A COMB IN YOUR POCKET?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, ARE
OCCASIONALLY SOMEONE HAS A HAIR
BALL COME UP AND WE HAVE TO USE
THOSE COMBS AS A TONGUE
DEPRESSOR.
SO WE HAVE TO KEEP STERILIZED AT
ALL TIMES.
STEVE: OKAY.
YOU ARE JUST JOKING.
DAVID, YOU ARE HIS ATTORNEY, WHY
IS IT HE OWES THOUSAND DOLLARS
INCLUDING COMB MONEY.
>> YEAH, $3,000, STEVE, MINOR
TECHNICALITIES RIDICULOUS.
60 YEARS AS A BARBER.
HE HAS NEVER HAD A COMPLAINT AND
THEN THEY ISSUE THESE MAXIMUM
FINES.
$6,000 OF THE FINE IS FOR HIS
PROTESTING THE GOVERNOR’S
ILLEGAL EXECUTIVE ORDERS.
OUR SUPREME COURT SAID THEY WERE
ILLEGAL AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
HE PROTESTED AGAINST THEM.
THEY ARE FINDING HIM $6,000 FOR
PROTESTING.
STEVE, ONE OF THE BORDER MEMBERS
ON THIS BORDER THAT MADE THIS
DECISION TESTIFIED AGAINST KARL
AT HIS HEARING.
I MEAN, THE UNFAIRNESS OF THIS
IS BREATH-TAKING AND WE ARE
GOING TO FIGHT IT.
WE ARE GOING TO APPEAL TO THE
COURT IMMEDIATELY.
WE ARE GOING TO GET INTO A REAL
COURT AND WE WILL SEE WHAT THEY
SAY ABOUT IT.
STEVE: KARL, YOU HAVE WON YOUR
COURT CASES.
THIS IS NOW JUST THE STATE
FINDING YOU FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS.
ARE YOU GOING TO PAY THIS MONEY?
>> YOU KNOW, I’M NOT GOING TO
PAY THIS MONEY BUT YOU KNOW, I
WANT TO REALLY THANK ALL THE
PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT HAVE
SUPPORTED ME WITH THIS THING.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE GOVERNOR
TRIES TO DO AND WHAT GOVERNMENTS
HAVE A TENDENCY TO DO UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS TO BECOME
TYRANNICAL IN THE SENSE THAT
THEY CAN INTIMIDATE PEOPLE BY --
THEY HAVE THE POCKETS ARE NEVER
ENDING.
WE HAVE ONLY A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
FUNDS.
THEY KNOW THEY CAN BREAK US.
SO THEY INTIMIDATE THE CITIZENS,
USING THIS PARTICULAR TYPE OF
DRACONIAN POWER.
SO I THANK ALL THE PEOPLE OUT
THERE THAT HAVE, YOU KNOW,
SUPPORTED ME FINANCIALLY AND
SUPPORTED ME SPIRITUALLY AND
MENTALLY AND PHYSICALLY.
WE HAVE GO FUND MES THAT ARE
HELPING ME QUITE A BIT, YOU
KNOW, IF IT WASN’T FOR THOSE,
THESE GOVERNORS WOULD -- I WOULD
BE IN JAIL.
I WOULD BE IN JAIL RIGHT NOW.
JUST AS SHE PUT IN PRISON THE
LADY FROM ME ME MELANIA OVER ON
OTHER SIDE OF THE STATE THEY
WOULD DO THE SAME TO ME.
STEVE: 2K5EU6D, THE REASON HE
FACED SCRUTINY IS WHEN GOVERNOR
WHITMER LOCKED DOWN HE SAID
AFTER A WHILE YOU CAN’T DO.
THIS ULTIMATELY YOU WON THOSE
CASES.
WHAT IS THE MORAL TO THE STORY
ABOUT HOW THEY WENT AFTER YOUR
CLIENT?
>> WELL, AGAIN, STEVE, I THINK
PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
VIRUS IS REAL THERE ARE ISSUES
PEOPLE SHOULD USE COMMON SENSE.
THAT DOESN’T MEAN THE STATE CAN
TRAMPLE OUR CIVIL RIGHTS AND
TRAMPLE ON THE CONSTITUTION AND
DO IT ILLEGAL WAY.
THAT’S WHAT’S BEEN HAPPENING IN
OUR STATE.
PEOPLE NEED TO WAKE UP AND STAND
UP AND PUSH BACK ON THESE SORTS
OF ACTIVITIES.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT.
KARL, YOU HAVE BEEN THROUGH THE
RINGER OVER THE LAST YEAR, WOULD
YOU DO IT AGAIN?
>> I WOULD DO IT IN A HEART
BEAT.
YOU KNOW, I’M AN AMERICAN.
SOMEONE COINED ME AS AMERICA’S
BARBER.
I LIKE THAT.
I’M AN AMERICAN AND A BARBER.
CAN I STAND UP AGAINST THIS IT
PARTICULAR TYPE OF TYRANNY, IT’S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, IT’S IMMORAL,
IT’S DRACONIAN.
I CAN’T FIND ENOUGH ADJECTIVES
TO DESCRIBE THIS ADMINISTRATION
THAT WE HAVE HERE IN MICHIGAN
RIGHT NOW.
STEVE: I UNDERSTAND.
YOU ARE A GREAT BARBER BUT A
LOUSY DOCTOR.
DO NOT USE A COMB AS A TONGUE